good evening a pretty unusual theft to
tell you about tonight a local company's
hot air balloon missing in action the
basket the balloon the tank all stolen
from a locked lot good evening I'm
Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftis it is
the company's largest and most expensive
balloon to worth nearly two hundred
thousand dollars Madison Kimbrough live
in studio with the exclusive story
you'll only see right here on eight yeah
Denise and Brian went inflated this
balloon is nearly 15 stories high in
tonight local companies like Vegas
balloon rides warning the public that
the chemicals inside the tank are highly
flammable and can be extremely dangerous
foreign
there's 400 pounds of flammable gas
inside of this if for some reason they
studied lighted on fire when they want
to get rid of it they can destroy
wherever it is it being a hot air
balloon owners JJ padro Allende and John
Francois rigolay of Vegas balloon rides
stunned that their biggest balloon was
stolen from their back lot it was a an
open flatbed trailer around 18 feet long
that contained the whole basket none of
those parts will be easy to sell on any
kind of markets so we expect them to
just dump them in a desert or in a small
Street somewhere this 175 thousand
dollar balloon is capable of holding 16
passengers and the owners say it's what
keeps the business afloat so they're
hoping someone saw something and can
help them get their investment back it's
a big shock we definitely never thought
that our heart balloon would be stolen
we are a family business here none of us
are related but we're very tight-knit a
lot of us depend on this and this is our
livelihood this balloon was the largest
in their Fleet at 150 feet tall when
inflated this loss coming at a tough
time due to Valentine's Day being one of
their busiest seasons
now as for security video Vegas balloon
rides are relying on businesses across
the way who may have caught it on camera
but now they plan to up their security
by installing better lighting cameras
and tracking devices for their trailers
and vehicles back to you